it's a perilous operation it's a
perilous place to go it's dangerous
inhospitable hostile and the
circumstance at which this vessel
disappeared was extremely odd one hour
45 into a dive on a conventional dive
profile that we would do that takes it
down to about two two and a half
thousand meters anyway effective unit
danger zone as soon as you leave the
mothership to be out of communication
this length of time irrespective of the
uh reported banging and so on it's not
looking very very promising let's face
it the ocean's a busy place there's a
lot of mammal activity we got bumped by
whales on him on our descents and
there's cable laying vessels there's
trenching going on there's propellers
noise travels fast through water it's a
great medium it's crucial we find this
vessel would be ever a diminishing hope
we can find and be on board who's alive
but more importantly post event there's
going to be a massive inquiry and I'm
sure legislation and regulations become
Tighter and more scrutinizing
foreign
[Music]